the latest American Horror Story teaser
has been released bringing the grand
total to 25 trailers we know from the
show's creators that all but one or
false leads but we did find a common
theme throughout these trailers classic
Hollywood horror films let's take a look
at a few this teaser is definitely
referencing the horror classic The Hills
Have Eyes the imagery speaks for itself
if you've ever seen the 1974 horror
classic it's alive then you know this
scene as an homage creepy is an
understatement and it's going to be
really hard to find a babysitter The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre at first glance
this teaser could be referencing any
number of films but listen this one's
pretty short but an obvious nod to the
people under the stairs keep reaching
for the stars I mean the angles you
should automatically know this one but
just in case this comical teaser
references the 1954 classic Creature
from the Black Lagoon
there's currently 25 teaser trailers out
for season 6 so let us know which ones
we missed and what you want to see this
season
thankfully all of our questions will be
answered soon as season six hits TV on
the 14th